SCP-682 Vs SCP-2855.
They say that money makes the world go round,
but can Mr. Money put the reptile underground?
SCP-2855, or Mr. Money, is
part of Dr. Wondertainment’s
Little Misters series.
His ability is having whatever capabilities
his buyer believes he has, so he was sold
to a member of the O5 Council as “A man
who can permanently destroy SCP-682, and will
do so immediately upon completion of this
transaction.”
However, this didn’t happen.
Instead, he disappeared for an hour, during
which time SCP-682 seemed to show no ill effects.
He later reappeared next to the Council Member,
dazed and experiencing memory loss, with a
note that read:
“Oops!
Dr. Wondertainment offers the sincerest of
apologies for the unanticipated malfunction
of your Mr. MoneyTM.
We will be working to correct this error in
future products.”